what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with strange academy yes we are
uh it took us long enough but we're
finishing volume one
uh i know i'm doing it about two weeks
after i originally started it um i'm
trying to figure out a day to do it
right and i thought about sunday's what
we're doing we're releasing invincible
although we are almost done so we might
start doing it on sundays afterwards i
don't know i'll figure it out anyway
strange academy right so in the first
video we basically covered the idea that
strange academy is essentially marvel's
version of hogwarts it's basically all
it is right you have all these young
people who are all learning their
magical abilities now the first video
was really them just kind of settling in
getting used to the fact that they were
at school getting kind of a i guess a
brief synopsis over what their courses
were going to be right so like a
syllabus basically but uh the first
thing we end up doing is switching over
to yeah right the ancient one kind of
returning here uh really before the
events of strange academy but remember
steven strange is the sorcerer supreme
so it's not like one of those things
where when yao returned he could just
kind of overtake that role from stephen
strange again but one of the things that
he talks about here is basically a
history of mystical objects now this is
an important part of magic when it comes
to marvel comics that you do have magic
in so far is like it's basically ambient
energy that exists out there in the
universe and a person of sufficient
magical abilities can tap into that
ambient energy to achieve a variety of
different things but there's also
magical artifacts that exist out there
things like the casket of ancient
winters and so on and so forth right the
uh the wand of a tomb or the eye of
agamotto which is both the third eye
which we'll talk about here in a little
bit as well as a physical artifact that
stephen strange wears but one of the
things that goes on is yao basically
says that he has essentially a genie and
a lamp that's referred to as a gen now
as i understand it and i'm not going to
swear by this right i'm not overly
knowledgeable about genies as i
understand it like the whole aladdin
genie and the lamp played by robin
williams granting you all your wishes
and just being a really cool guy that's
not how it works and as i understand it
they'll grant you a wish but they
usually do it in a deceptive way and
then they'll steal your soul when you're
done i don't know if that's true why i
have no idea how much of that is
actually real i mean obviously genies
are a thing of myth but nonetheless
right the whole task that's assigned to
them is get the genie back in the lamp
without using your powers now that's one
of the things that i want to point out
here these little lessons that they get
in this little tidbit of a video it's
fast-paced stuff i mean literally it's
like three different classes and three
different panels all on one page one of
the things that jericho drum basically
deals with them or at least introduces
them to is the idea of zombies and one
of the things that he says is zombies
are not depicted like they don't exist
in the way they do in movies right where
it's like people who come back from the
dead and you like shoot them in the face
and like they die it doesn't really work
that way instead there's all kinds of
different zombies right there are
zombies that are kind of dead but not
really there are like the traditional
zombies like beings who rise from the
dead right just all these different
concepts they're familiar with it's not
necessarily that way the other thing
about this is that for doyle dormammu
one of the things is that despite the
fact that he's the son of dormammu and
he has a lot of magical ability at his
disposal he's not readily capable of
using it and that's one of the things
that really comes to him when he's in
scarlet witch's class which is yes
you're capable and you're powerful but
you need to basically study your book on
chaos magic
you need to learn how to use the magical
energy that's available to you because
being the son of dormammu does not
necessarily mean you are inherently able
to use it the other part of this is that
they all have they all have pe right
physical education i don't know about
you guys pe was always my favorite part
of school like whenever we would play
like like basketball or we would play
like badminton that was always the most
fun or like volleyball that was always
really really fun but nonetheless so you
get to basically what's fifth period and
you end up having these uh you end up
having like magic and and uh damon
hellstrom who are basically running this
class now the reason why is because what
she says is it's a course that's
basically designed to teach them about
the nature of hell right limbo now
remember the whole idea of inferno limbo
all that kind of stuff magic is not true
limbo right where magic comes from it's
not true limbo it's a kind of purgatory
hell-like version of limbo right true
limbo that's where kane the conqueror
became a mortise right that's where all
that happens but in terms of where she's
from it's more inferno slash limbo but
it's basically teaching them about the
layers of hell and the different magical
properties of it now what also ends up
happening here is that uh eric one of
the asgardian twins just kind of
casually makes his way in here and he's
like yeah i had a hard time finding the
class it was a little tough uh but i
made it you know and ultimately magic's
like okay like you can't come in here
late like whenever you want to and he's
like well i mean what are you gonna do
about it and damon hellstrom's like you
just said the wrong thing and magic's
like you know what we're not having this
today right we're laying down the rules
day one she transports him to hell
she teleports him to inferno and then
when doyle dormammu because him and uh
because him and eric are like like
they're enemies they're not really big
friends or anything like that doyle's
like yeah it serves them right you did a
great job you know miss rasputin and
she's like you know what you get to go
too and then she teleports him to hell
too imagine that guys imagine if in
school you instead of getting sent to
safe they send you to hell which i guess
depending on your school might as well
be but nonetheless right it's just one
of those things they get transported to
the to the realm of limbo and they
basically have to fight their way up now
there is an important thing that does
come out of this right one of the
important things that goes on is that
for emily she's very very curious
remember emily is kind of the star of
the comic but not necessarily it's
really more of the group of kids but
it's like harry potter right i mean like
harry potter's the star of the movie but
like hermione and ron are there all the
time like you know what i mean it's like
which one's really the star you know i
guess it depends on which one you like
most but like it's hairy you know so one
of the things that goes on is she asked
the question that when she was
originally picked up or i guess rescued
from like the the magical tree right
that she had encountered when she first
used her powers when she was rescued by
zelma one of the things that zelma said
is there is a price to using magic and
when emily asked the question what is
this price i mean we're using magic
willy-nilly here when i first used it
there i felt like i was being turned
inside out but here i don't really feel
any effects of using magic the response
to zelma is well we took care of that
right we got all that taken care of now
this is a little bit of a shady thing
that goes on here because there is a
point when you end up having uh jericho
drum talking with the rest of the staff
and zelma brings up the idea that like
emily is asking about the price of magic
and the response of jericho is well what
did you tell her and she's in the old
zeon says well we took care of it he's
like and we did you know but ultimately
it all really just seems to be a lie
that they're lying to the students when
they say they satisfied the the cost of
using magic now in terms of that price
we'll talk about that later because that
comes more that becomes more important
as we get closer and really to the end
of the the strange academy storyline so
we will i definitely won't leave you
guys hanging on that but as far as like
being transported to the realm of
inferno it's the funniest thing ever so
like eric and doyle dormammu are like i
mean they're they're rivals right i mean
their rivals in so far is like they have
a grudging respect for each other but
like neither one wants to admit it so
it's easier to just stand there and like
be tough and so like they're literally
fighting these demons and like doyle's
like look man you gotta watch your back
dude like i'm getting tired of saving
you and you're like i didn't ask for
your help you know as a matter of fact i
don't need your help and then doyle's
like well then i'll stop helping you
when you stop helping me right like i
need help even less than you do and
eric's like yeah right man but it's like
it's one of those things like i'm not
helping you i'm helping myself get out
of here right like neither one can cast
their pride aside long enough to be like
all right look man we're gonna die here
if we don't work together so let's just
work together get the hell out of here
and then we can worry about our rivalry
once we live and once we're back home
you know once we're safe but it's a cute
little thing now the other part of this
is that with zoe something's always kind
of seeming to go on there right she's
kind of like this mysterious character
that nobody really seems to know a whole
lot about right she's just sort of there
and and the truth is that they kind of
treat her as just a person who is part
of the strange academy but you don't
necessarily know the ins and outs of it
now desi is a person who actually comes
from the realm of inferno right from the
realm of hell and she knows there's
something going on with with zoey right
she knows it like zoe is not all she
appears to be but she always asks the
question she's always kind of looking at
her and she's always like what are you
going to tell people what you really are
right like when are you going to reveal
what's actually going on with you now
the other part of this is that once they
switch over to kind of the next day or
really the i guess that friday and
they're talking with yao what the
ancient one is teaching them is
basically how to use the third eye right
the eye of agamotto now again the eye of
agamotto appears in a couple different
ways in marvel comics and it's been
depicted different ways over time so one
of the ways in which it's been depicted
is that it's just a physical amulet that
doctor strange wears and that allows him
that gives him quote-unquote the sight
which allows him to sort of see beyond
the physical realm into the metaphysical
realm other times he uses the eye of
agamotto to cast a third eye which is
what gives him the vision so and there
have been other times where he never
uses the amulet and he just has the
third eye and it's the eye of agamotto
it's just kind of been it's really
switched back and forth a lot over the
years of marvel comics which is bound to
happen when you have a guy who's been
around since the 60s right you're
talking about 60 some odd years of
comics just kind of of different writers
changing things and switching things and
so on and so forth but what the ancient
one is teaching them is how to use their
third eye because whenever they use
their two physical eyes to see the world
they see the physical world but by
opening their third eye what it allows
them to do is basically see the
metaphysical world now while everybody's
trying right and they're just like
they're they're like squinting and like
grunting and they're just like oh i'm
trying you know and all that kind of
stuff trying to force the whole thing
you guys you guys see what i'm talking
about um that emily successfully is able
to pull it off and when that happens she
actually sees essentially the
metaphysical world now the way it's
depicted here artistically is just
designed to show us the difference
between the physical world and the
metaphysical world but the reality here
is that the metaphysical world allows
you to see things that the human eye
just can't see all these magical beings
that exist out there something that i
want to point out is that there does
come a point in time when a person of
sufficient magical ability could choose
to see this way all the time somebody
like doctor strange could do that even
without using his third eye he could
just see this metaphysical realm all the
time and the ancient one even says as
much now for steven strange sometimes he
does sometimes he doesn't he'll do that
if like something seems odd but by and
large you'll just kind of walk around as
a normal guy and see the world the way a
guy normally does but one of the things
that this is really designed to teach
them is that that while stephen strange
sees these it's kind of almost parasites
to a degree that yao sees them it's
really more of kind of a balancing act
right that they borrow magical energy
from them they give magical magical
energy to these various beings who exist
out there but the point of this is to
illustrate that it's not just like
humans and animals floor and fauna that
live in the world that there are all
kinds of things that the human eye just
can't readily see that exist out there
because they're beyond the ability for
folks to normally understand and so what
you end up getting is basically all
these kids right who end up you know
taking the weekend to themselves yeah i
was like enjoy your weekend guys you
guys are good right just you know have
fun i'll see you guys on monday and they
end up going to uh going to like bourbon
street in new orleans going to the
french quarter which by the way if you
ever go to new orleans never get food on
bourbon street get food at the places
off of bourbon street right that's where
the best food is man that's that's where
the best food is i've been in new
orleans before man like it's just it's
phenomenal but they end up kind of going
around they're like you know wanting to
get some beignets and stuff like that
you know and they're kind of joking
about zombies and things along those
lines which kind of throws zoe off to a
degree which makes sense zombies never
really make anybody comfortable uh but
there does come a point when they end up
meeting with an old woman who claims to
be a cirrus right the ability to see
everything that's going on and what ends
up happening here is where she initially
approaches emily and says like i want to
give you your vision emily says no but
doyle dormammu agrees and so when that
happens he basically you know she
basically says like miss hazel right
she's just gonna show you the show you
what your future holds or at least what
your future seems to hold right as a
kind of a series of prophetic visions
when doyle dormammu gets this he ends up
seeing what looked like tree people and
then basically either himself or
dormammu essentially conquering the
world right and destroying everyone and
everything they care about that
seemingly the fate of doyle dormammu and
the power of doyle dormammu is such that
he will ruin the world like he will
destroy the world and it makes sense
right dormammu is always trying to find
a way back into the main marvel universe
when you take that concept and you apply
it to his son who's already here one his
son could basically exist as like a
vector a means by which storm amu could
enter into these physical realms he
could simply just do it of his own
accord right for any number of reasons i
mean he's a teenager right his hormones
are going crazy all that kind of stuff
he asked emily out emily says no he's
like destroy the world right it makes
sense you know when you're like a
teenage kid you're like 15 years old you
can't control yourself so it's one of
those crazy things because when that
happens it's really too much for doyle
to be able to handle and in fact miss
hazel kind of gets carried away with it
and so what zoe ends up doing is
actually casting a kind of magical spell
that forces miss hazel off and that's
when ms hazel realizes that zoe is a
tranquil now we'll find out what that
means here in a little bit but basically
she's a person who's versus magical
energy following that what you end up
getting is them basically running to the
to the to the aid of like one of their
friends who stuck out in an alley and
basically being picked on by a few
bullies you know who consider him kind
of a loser and kind of weird you know
basically making fun of calvin is this
kid in particular and it's one of those
things where like he's like look man
like you really don't want to do this
like if you if you start a fight with me
i promise you you will end up getting
hurt well they end up taking that as a
challenge right because they don't see
him as somebody who's serious now the
rest of the strange academy show up
right the rest of the kids show up here
but they all agree they're not going to
assault these bullies because if that
happens they could destroy them right
like they could absolutely annihilate
these guys right they could actually end
up killing them and so what ends up
happening is that instead of like
fighting them physically and destroying
them emily helps them to understand
their place in the bigger picture right
casting their third eye and giving them
the ability to see the metaphysical
realm and basically realize there's all
these different things around them the
guys end up going nuts believing they're
being eaten and then just take off right
they just end up running off right so
helping these bullies to understand
where they reside in the grand scheme of
things and they're much lower on the
totem pole than they initially led
themselves to believe now while all
that's going on you basically have these
weird tree people who are essentially
watching these kids and realizing how
powerful they are and basically declare
their desire to essentially consume them
right to consume their magical energy or
their capabilities or what have you now
of course these guys are basically like
the main enemy of the story right and
what you end up finding out is that they
are in effect what they refer to as the
holo right what they end up saying here
is that these waters and trees these
vines and creatures that crawl up on
them have been poisoned by the rot of
man and drained of their power by bottom
feeders of magic we have learned that
some of them are here now feeding on the
last of our old power wasting it on
children which basically of course
they're talking about the strange
academy that because the nature of
magical energy is that it imbues
everything right it's like the force the
star wars right it surrounds us and
binds us you know do or do not there is
no try luke skywalker like that kind of
whole thing right that like magical
energy permeates everything that these
guys seem to kind of come from the
perspective that like there is a sort of
balance that has to be struck you have
to give what you get and that what seems
to be going on with the strange academy
and the teachers
in particular in terms of how they're
training the students is that they're
just using magic willy-nilly right
they're not giving back what it is that
they take and the holo seems to be more
more in line with maintaining that
balance like they're the tree huggers of
the magical world and so the results of
this is that you basically switch over
to the kids kind of going you know doing
their whole experience and studying and
you know kind of being in school but
desi finally runs up on zoe and says
okay like what like like you need to
reveal to everybody what else is going
on and she's like and i want to know
here how is it that you're able to hide
what you really are and that's when she
realizes it's the necklace because
everywhere that zoe goes she always has
the necklace on her outfits change her
clothes change but the necklace never
does and she ends up basically snatching
the necklace away from zoe and when that
happens it's revealed that zoe's a
zombie now the only person that that
sees this at the moment is desi nobody
else does of course zoey ends up taking
the amulet back and ends up putting the
necklace around her neck and goes back
into basically appearing as her normal
form but the reason why nobody else sees
this is because they're experiencing
what is quite possibly the most fun
thing that anybody could ever experience
ever they are playing an
inter-dimensional game of tag like
literally they're they're like chasing
after each other through different
dimensions and i'm not even gonna lie it
looks like the most fun ever like it
looks it looks absolutely amazing
[Laughter]
right there's one point where like like
they end up like sheila ends up running
up on on emily and it's like tag you're
it right and then like emily's like what
in the heck are you talking about she's
like you have to tag where you come from
right they're like she's like yeah it's
like okay well instead of running around
a yard we're running around dimensions
so uh you got to get one of us and then
she races through a door now as soon as
emily follows her through that door she
ends up falling out of what's basically
a skyscraper and is rescued by
spider-man which looks really really
amazing but literally their game right
their whole game of tag it goes through
asgard it goes through weird world right
it just goes through all these different
places until they end up in a realm of
at least a darker realm that's seemingly
locked away now one of the things about
this is we don't necessarily find out
exactly how this happened all we know is
they seem to have stumbled across a book
somebody opened it and unleashed this
demonic entity now of course this
basically leads to like zelma stepping
in and essentially helping to save the
day right like you know removing this
this magical force and confining them
back to the book that they came from and
so on but it's just one of those things
where it's like they're they were toying
with magical energy that they didn't
necessarily fully understand but for
emily herself she's actually a bit lost
and she's just kind of stumbling through
like this magical realm right through
world world to a degree and she ends up
coming across a uh a critter that refers
to itself as cat beast right now cat b
seems more kind like a spiritual guide
and it's kind of like okay look like i
mean i can help you get out of here and
help you get back home so like just
follow me and when they end up traveling
through one of the doors they end up in
dr strange's sanctum sanctorum but when
they get downstairs into the basement
they end up coming across or at least
hearing the voice of a person who's
seemingly locked away now we don't know
who this person is though they're
basically being kept prisoner by stephen
strange of course emily ends up making
her escape right before steven strange
comes down there and ultimately would
have caught her but she ends up
returning back the problem with this
though is that while she was able to
find her way back calvin is also missing
and calvin's the last guy who is missing
and so nobody realizes that calvin had
essentially landed in the swamp where
the hollow reside and so while he's
there trying to navigate the space and
trying to figure out what's going on
he's ultimately captured and one of the
funny things that goes on is that he's
basically designed to be bait but he
doesn't know he's big and in fact he
actually tells these guys in the hollow
he's like look you know like you need to
let me go because if you don't my
friends are going to come looking for me
they're going to find me and
like they're gonna save me right they're
gonna come to this place and the
hollow's like fantastic that's exactly
what we wanted so you're saying all we
have to do is just wait and then like
they will come here well hell man like
then yeah we'll just chill right we'll
go play cards we'll go we'll go play
ronnie you know and then when they
appear then yeah then we'll deal with
them then because getting you all here
by yourselves that's kind of what we've
been shooting for so thanks for letting
us know that we just need to chill and
wait right we're gonna go watch golden
girls
we'll see you in a little bit you know
and that's basically yeah right it's
just kind of a funny little thing but
the reality here is that emily realizes
calvin's gone and the teachers have
realized calvin's gone the thing about
this though is that it's been like a day
right almost like a day and a half and
no one's seen calvin so they all end up
going to search the students launched
their own search and then the teachers
launched their own search now the
students do this without the teachers
knowing because the teachers really
wouldn't be a huge fan of this but they
end up tracking him down to the swamp
where he was initially taken and so the
result of this is basically them meeting
the hollow right like meeting all these
guys and it's funny because each one of
these kids ends up basically launching
an attack against them but the hollow
are capable the other part of this is
that the hollow referred to at least
when this this coming together happens
they're like wow you know like i don't
believe it right they say i knew i felt
a great power arrive in these uh in
these past months but could not have
predicted it would be you the one and
the funny thing is we're not really
given a definitive answer on who it is
that we're they're referring to
contextually given like the vision from
earlier and so on and so forth you could
go with doyle dormammu but the way it's
been perceived so far and the fact that
emily is kind of like the main star that
it's her that she seems to have just
this incredible raw magical energy the
first one to be able to access the third
eye but to a degree magic seems to come
very easy to her it doesn't mean she
doesn't have to work for it but her
ability to access her magical energy
seems to come easier from seemingly
everybody else especially because she's
just a regular person right and so the
thing about this is that while each one
of them are attacking the hollow the
reality is these guys have been
practicing magic for quite some time and
so they basically know what they're
doing but these kids are fairly new and
they literally pull out all the stops
right there's one point where like zoe
rips off her necklace and because she is
a zombie she's able to summon other
zombies the problem is she can't hold
this very long because it's a relatively
new power to her so while she is able to
summon them temporarily right for like a
few moments they all basically end up
just kind of collapsing almost almost as
soon as they basically emerge right
they're just kind of like oh
and like that's it right that's that's
literally like imagine if a zombie
crawled out of the ground and then just
collapsed and like that was it they'd be
like damn that zombie's exhausted man i
guess crawling out of the ground is a
pretty tiring thing you know like we'll
give it a minute to rest
you know that's kind of how it ends up
coming across and so the result of this
is that they end up seizing dormammu
kind of accessing a portion of his power
to a degree and then channeling that
basically against everybody else and one
of the crazy things is that as that
happens you basically end up getting
emily who just loses it right like and
seeing what looks like doyle dormammu
being assaulted by these guys and and
basically like begging you know begging
for his life right like assumingly this
idea that he's gonna die that she just
loses it right this girl goes full gohan
those you guys ever watch dragon ball
you know exactly what i'm talking about
and this insane level of power emerges
right just like an insane level of
magical energy and in fact she actually
begins to lose herself she starts to
lose control and then it gets to the
point where she just collapses under the
sheer amount of power that she has it's
more than she can control right now
here's the thing to keep in mind here
this is one of the things because a lot
of people are going to ask well if it's
all her power then like surely how can
it overwhelm her the reality is here
remember when it comes to magical energy
you're not using your own inherent power
you're using the power of basically the
universe right you're manipulating
ambient magical energy the truth about
this is it's it's kind of like the
magical equivalent to a person who's a
telepath if you are an untrained
telepath you won't know how to filter
out people's voices you'll literally
just be bombarded with everything that
everybody's saying around you all the
time and like that will be it it'll
overwhelm you and it'll probably end up
sending you into like a catatonic state
if you're you know assuming that you
don't lose your mind and stay conscious
right but like that's being overwhelmed
in a mental state the the physical
effect of magic that's what overwhelmed
emily and that's why she basically just
ended up collapsing now of course as
this happens that's when the big guns
show right you got man thing right so
will be tied any of these members of the
hollow if they're scared remember those
who feel fear burn at the touch of the
man thing like you literally burn like
you literally die there's jericho drum
which is pretty badass and then there's
doctor strange and when doctor strange
shows up here he's like nope done like
literally caesar's control of these guys
confines them all into a singular tree
and it's like you guys are just magical
zealots i've met a million of you guys
before these kids think you're a big
deal because they've never met anything
like you before but you're just a bunch
of crazy [ __ ] who are messing around
with magic and are pissed off because
people aren't giving back right like
whatever hippies and so he ends up
basically confining them all binding
them all into the form of like a
singular tree and then they cast a spell
that basically says that in this form
they will experience all the ages of the
earth seemingly they're stuck here until
the world ends right until like the
earth itself is physically destroyed
right and like that's basically it so
seemingly there won't really be anything
else going on here the only way that
this would be undone is if somebody
undoes the spell right somebody breaks
the spell that's cast on there but there
are two big things that come out of this
the first is that emily has a huge
amount of magical energy right this is
kind of established here that her
ability to access all this magical power
is immense does she rival someone like
dr strange or the scarlet witch at the
moment we don't know it's possible right
remember the difference between someone
like doctor strange and the scully witch
is that the scarlet witch can access
chaos magic doctor strange can't right
he can't really use chaos magic i mean i
guess he could but he would have to
invoke the power of catholic in order to
do it and that's a big no-no right
that's a door you don't want to unlock
for someone like emily she can seemingly
manipulate every form of magical energy
that exists out there right so if we're
saying that the ability to manipulate
magic is a hallway of doors and behind
each one of these doors is a magical
being say somebody like odin and sacha
phone and say like dormammu and and like
sidorak just a few of the people behind
there right vishanti and so on and so
forth for someone like doctor strange
those doors may or may not be unlocked
he may not even be able to see that
they're there right it's just a type of
magic that he simply just can't access
for someone like emily she can see every
door and she can access every door now
whether that's the case or not we don't
know only time will tell but the second
thing to come out of this is that as a
result of the experience doyle dormammu
is dead right doyle basically died the
son of dormammu is killed here which is
nuts because i'm gonna tell you guys
right now what comes after this is
absolutely bonkers but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace